I want to have my own show and I want to
produce I want to do everything that's
in fashion and I want to act you should
do everything you want to do and by the
way let me give you a really strong
thing to consider nine years when you're
in a different place in your life you
may change what you want to do yeah
today you may want to dominate the
fashion world but at 19 you may want to
become a doctor or you might want to
become an architect or interior design
right or paint never ever ever put
yourself in a position where you're not
willing to change your mind on what you
want to do
wow yeah you're really smart thanks you
are too thank you